Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Logbuchnetzpolitik, die neunte, Ausgabe und außerdem die erste im Jahre zwanzig zwölf und das, was man eine Sonderausgabe nennt.
Genau, ja, wir machen eine Sonderausgabe. Das gehört, das macht man ja so.
Genau. Das kann man sich schon mal leisten, nach acht Sendungen.
Was wäre das Leben ohne zumal wir ja auch zwangsläufig ähm Weihnachts und Kongresspausen bedingt hier äh unseren Wochenzyklus nicht durchgehalten haben, den werden wir dann aber auch wieder aufnehmen.
Ähm in doppelter Hinsicht, denn diese Folge wird sofort einer,
von einer weiteren gefolgt, die dann quasi eine normale ist und das hier ist unser achtundzwanzig C drei Special, also wir berichten vom achtundzwanzigsten Chaos Kongress,
denn da waren wir.
Wir sind äh dort rumgelaufen und haben aufgenommen.
Und wir haben schöne Interviews gemacht und äh.
In dem Sinne wollen wir euch hier vor allem mal mit diesen Interviews ein bisschen beglücken. Wir haben mit ein paar Leuten gesprochen, die Themen behandeln, die äh unserer Meinung nach hier in Lokbuchnetz Politik reinpassen,
Und ja, legen wir doch mal gleich los.
Der erste Kandidat ist Dodja vom CCC Hamburg, das wird auch gleich nochmal gesagt, da geht's um eine Initiative,
für ein Transparenzgesetz. Zunächst einmal in Hamburg, wobei das auch so ein bisschen als Testballon gesehen werden kann,
für ähm weitere Aktivitäten. Das wird aber aus diesem Interview auch äh eigentlich schnell klar. So dann noch irgendwo eine Anmerkung zu machen.
Transparenzgesetz,
interessante Sache, aber ich glaube, äh Deutschland hat das dermaßen ideal, ist dermaßen super da erklärt, da braucht man, glaube ich, wenig noch mehr dazu zu sagen, außer, dass wir natürlich die Volksinitiative Transparenz schafft Vertrauen.
Erwähnen sollten und die gibt's natürlich auch in den Links zur Sendung.
Genau. Also jetzt erstmal viel Spaß hier im ersten Gespräch mit Dodja.
Jetzt sind wir hier äh in der Cafeteria des achtundzwanzig C drei und haben unser erstes Opfer gefunden und zwar Dodja. Hallo Dodja.
Hallo, moin.
Du gehörst ja auch zum Club in Hamburg und also zum CCC, Club ist, wenn man hier Club sagt, dann meint man immer CCC. Ähm.
Und was da beteiligt an einer Initiative oder beziehungsweise bis beteiligt an einer Initiative für mehr Transparenz auf Landesebene in Hamburg.
Äh
Habe ich das richtig zusammengefass.
Ja, soweit richtig. Ähm das ist eine Volksinitiative, die ein Transparenzgesetz geschrieben hat. Wir haben also gesagt, äh Gesetze schreiben kann ja eigentlich jeder und ähm was die Politiker da so an Transparenz und an Open Data machen, gefällt uns noch nicht so richtig,
Wir machen das mal selber.
Was fehlt euch denn da? Was fehlt euch denn?
Was fehlt uns denn? Na ja, zum einen hast du bestes Beispiel. Ähm du kriegst den Hamburger Haushalt als PDF, den kannst du dir ausdrucken, der hat so achthundert Seiten,
und als Hacker will man natürlich ähm mit den Daten auch was anfangen können und das nicht nur ausdrucken. Und dann haben wir mal ähm nach Informationsfreiheitsgesetz angefragt und haben den Haushalt als Excel Tabelle haben wollen,
Es hat drei Wochen gedauert, die Tabelle zu kriegen, hundertfünfundzwanzig Euro Bearbeitungsgebirge kostet.
Das ist dann auf offener Haushalt DE gelandet, aber das ist halt der Punkt, die produzieren.
Produzieren mit Bürgergeldern Daten und erwirtschaften Informationen und die Bürger kommen nicht.
Also vielleicht noch, um das kurz zu erklären. Excel-Tabelle deshalb, weil man dann äh mit den Daten überhaupt was anfangen kann, ne? Aus dem PDF äh kann man die Daten dann nicht wirklich direkt weiterverarbeiten für unsere Hörer.
Genau, dann kann man das Ganze halt visualisieren und sieht dann ähm in bunten Klötzchen, wie viel eins Komma vier, fünf Milliarden eigentlich so sind. Im Vergleich zu dem ganzen Rest des Haushalts als Beispiel.
Und was was wollt ihr denn jetzt erreichen konkret?
Na, konkret geht es darum, dass die Stadt Hamburg nach dem Gesetz dann dazu gebracht,
alle Verträge, die sie schließt, alle Informationen, die sie mit Bürgergeldern kauft, sprich Steuergeldern,
und alles was irgendwo an Informationen vorliegt, Geodaten, Verträge, Abkommen, Gutachten vor allen Dingen, müssen in ein zentrales Register ins Netz gestellt werden,
und da kostenlos für jeden zur Verfügung stellen, damit er sie einsehen kann, weiterbearbeiten kann und auswerten.
Und was ist jetzt äh passiert bisher? Also was habt ihr getan? Falls ihr genau.
Passiert ist, dass die Initiative Transparenz schafft, Vertrauen. Äh das ist eine Initiative von Chaos Computerclub Hamburg, mehr Demokratie und Transparency International,
gemeinsam dieses Gesetz geschrieben haben, dann haben wir eine Volksinitiative eingereicht, dazu muss man mindestens zehntausend gültige Unterschriften von Hamburgern sammeln,
wir haben sechs Monate Zeit und wir haben innerhalb von sechs Wochen fünfzehntausend gesammelt und eingereicht. Also das Interesse ist da,
Das war jetzt der erste Schritt und jetzt muss die Bürgerschaft der Senat darüber beraten, ob sie das so annehmen.
Und äh müssen sie das nicht annehmen, ab einer bestimmten Zahl.
Ja, in Hamburg gibt's einen verbindlichen Volksentscheid.
Der ist nochmal dreistufig, das heißt, wenn sie's jetzt nicht annehmen, dann gehen wir ins Volksbegehren, das heißt, wir müssen äh im Sommer des Jahres dann ähm siebzigtausend Unterschriften sammeln, innerhalb von drei Wochen.
Und wenn die zusammen sind, dann kommt das Ganze bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl mit auf dem Wahlzettel zur Abstimmung. Und wenn das Volk sich dann dafür entscheidet, weil das Volk muss ja dann nochmal entscheiden, dann ist das ganze Landesgesetz.
Was heißt Sie in dem Zusammenhang? Ist das dann das der der Hamburger äh Landesregierung? Der Senat,
Senat kann jetzt sagen, wir nehmen das Ganze so an, wie es geschrieben ist oder sie können mit uns in Verhandlungen eintreten,
oder dritte Möglichkeit. Sie können sagen, nur interessiert uns mal gar nicht. Äh geht ihr mal ruhig ins Bürgerbegehren.
Klingt so ein bisschen, als ob die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es dann erstmal ins Bürgerbegehren geht, recht hoch ist.
Wir gehen davon aus, ja. Ja.
Und dann äh steht's bei der Bundestagswahl mit auf dem Wahlzettel. War das die nächste Wahl ist in Hamburg?
Ja, das ist ähm auch wieder so eine so eine Spezialität in Hamburg. Wir haben halt dieses verbindliche Volksbegehren durchgedrückt vor drei Jahren, auch mit dem Volksbegehren.
Und da ist auch mit reingeschrieben worden, dass es immer zwingend auf einen Wahltag fallen muss,
das wäre die nächste Wahl, die in Hamburg landesweit stattfindet, wäre die Bundestagswahl. Alternativheit, die Europawahl zweitausend.
Und das ist Kostenersparnis wahrscheinlich als Überlegung oder weshalb?
Na ja, das ist eigentlich ist es eher pragmatisch, weil wenn ich jetzt ein Volksbegehren einberufe und sage, geht nur um diese eine Entscheidung zu fällen ins Wahllokal, dann ist die Wahlbeteiligung sehr gering,
da ein Quorum, dass also von, dass mindestens zwanzig Prozent der Wähler äh der Wahlberechtigten dafür stimmen müssen und davon die Mehrheit,
entscheidet. Ja, also wenn jetzt nur neunzehn Prozent der Leute überhaupt zu der Abstimmung gehen, dann ist das Ding gestorben.
Das heißt durch die Bindung an eine Wahlhasse eigentlich wenn du, also solltest dir eigentlich sehr leicht immer gelegen, das Quorum zu kriegen, ist ja eigentlich eine sehr äh sehr kluge Lösung.
Genau, das ist also der der wichtige Punkt dabei. Ähm das ist auch ein Punkt in anderen Ländern, in anderen Bundesländern, woran halt Volksbegehren gerne scheitern. Dass das halt irgendein Termin ist und die Leute gehen dann halt nicht hin oder haben Urlaub oder liegen in der Sonne und keiner hat da Lust wegen einer Entscheidung dahin zu latschen.
Und was habt ihr jetzt so für äh Ressourcen äh aktiviert? Also es gibt ja sicherlich da die passende Webseite dazu. Gibt's noch andere Sachen sich dazu äh beteiligen, einzubringen.
Ja, also es gibt ähm im Moment jetzt äh äh bauen wir ja auf das Volksbegehren hin auf. Äh es gibt eine Webseite, Transparenzgesetz DE.
Einen Twitter-Kanal, Transparenz Unterstrich haha. Und es läuft also jetzt darauf hinaus, dass wenn wir ins Begehren gehen, dass wir ab dem siebenundzwanzigsten August drei Wochen lang sammeln.
Da sind alle Leute, die Lust haben und äh Erfahrung vielleicht sogar haben mit äh äh Unterschriften sammeln, herzlich eingeladen. Wir machen ein schickes Camp,
Camp, sondern ein Sammlercamp dieses Mal, wird aber auch sehr chillig dann abends mit Kino und so weiter, auf einem alten Bauernhof, äh in den vier landen.
Ne, da werden die Leute verpflegt, werden Preisekosten werden übernommen und dann kommen die Leute und sammeln aktiv zehn Stunden am Tag Unterschriften.
Also so eine Druckerkolone.
Quasi eine Drückerkolonne, aber halt ohne Waschmaschine und für die gute Sache.
Ja. Was ähm ich meine, wenn man jetzt so ein Gesetzesvorschlag macht, der muss ja dann auch juristisch wasserfest ausgearbeitet werden. Inwiefern ist denn das jetzt schon erfolgt oder wie fern ist das überhaupt eine Herausforderung?
Also wir haben da sind da auch ein bisschen blaue Geschran gegangen. Wir haben halt aufgeschrieben, was wir wollen. Alle Daten und alle Verträge, Punkt. So fertig.
Genau, dann haben wir ein bisschen weiter ausgefeilt, haben das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz natürlich mit reingenommen, weil das lösen wir ja quasi ab damit.
Ja. Ähm also du meinst das Bundes? Nee, das.
Hamburger, äh, das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz gibt's auf Landesebene jeweils auch.
Dann gab es einen Gesetzentwurf schon mal von den Berliner Piraten dazu, den haben wir auch mit einfließen lassen inhaltlich zum Teil.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, so jetzt lassen wir einen Juristen drübergucken und der hat uns das dann um die Ohren gehauen.
Das war äh der Herr Doktor Küling, das ist ein Bundesverfassungsrecht äh Richter AD, der zwölf Jahre Bundesverfassungsgericht, einer der angesehensten äh Verwaltungsrechtler in Deutschland.
Der hat uns gestern um die Ohren gehauen und hat gesagt, so jetzt setzen wir uns hin und schreiben das mal auf juristisch. Mhm. Und der hat dann die ganzen handwerklichen Sachen, die wir leihen gemacht haben, die Fehler natürlich ausgebügelt. Es steht, ist immer noch der Text oder der Inhalt, wie wir ihn wollen. Aber halt auf Juristendeutsch,
und mit einer vernünftigen Begründung dabei, also juristisch halten wir das Ganze und auch die Verwaltungsrechner, die es bisher angeschaut haben für äh wasserdicht,
Wir haben das Ganze auch transparent in dem Wickie, live von der ersten Minute an im Netz entwickelt, also es konnte jederzeit jeder äh Jurist draufgucken und reinschauen und wir haben noch einige Expertise eingeholt. Also das.
Und jetzt ist es in welchem Zustand.
Ja, das Gesetz ist fertig. Also es kann morgen angenommen werden.
Na, ist ja gut. Und äh wie sind so eure Erfahrungen gewesen so im Wicky, das zu machen, Konsensbildung? Ich meine, die Piraten setzen da auf Liquid Feedback, somit Vorschlägen und Annehmen und trallala. Ist das irgendwie für euch auch ein Weg gewesen?
Jein, ja, wir haben also ein wöchentliches Bündnistreffen gemacht, äh dieser Gründungsinitiativen, das heißt, wir haben dann jeweils sechs, sieben, zehn Leute am Tisch gehabt,
jeder hat seine Sachen reingebracht, die ihm wichtig sind, die Kernthemen, also für den Klub halt dann Open Data und so weiter.
Transparent International hat natürlich andere Ideen, weshalb sie da mitmachen,
das haben wir alles reingebracht und haben dann angefangen, das gemeinsam auszuformulieren, Punkte zu streichen, bei der Vertragsveröffentlichung zum Beispiel gibt's nur hunderttausend Euro Klausel,
Sprich, wenn die Verträge unter hunderttausend Euro innerhalb zwölf Monaten bleiben, dann sind sie nicht veröffentlichungspflichtig. Ganz einfach, weil sonst die Mietverträge mit dem Wohnungsbaugesellschaften, die der Stadt gehören, runterfallen.
Das sind so Fallstricke, an die man nicht denkt und wo man dann aber in der Gruppe irgendwann drauf kommt, so okay, stopp, da.
Warum sollte man die nicht veröffentlichen?
Naja, weil die Saga in Hamburg circa dreihunderttausend Wohneinheiten hat,
und ist ein städtischer Betrieb und jeder Mietvertrag eines jeden Bürgers und Kleingewerbe bleibt dann wieder der Datenschutz rein. Ja, okay. Hast du riesige einen Rattenschwanz und wir wollen die Verwaltung ja nicht lähmen, sondern verbessern.
Ja, na gut, jetzt können natürlich die großen äh Firmen auch schnell kommen mit so einem Argument mit hier äh Datenschutz und äh wer schützt uns denn? Was ist denn da so eure Argumentation?
Ja, das steht im Gesetz drin und auch in der Begründung, ähm wenn eine Firma begründete Geschäftsgeheimnisse in dem Vertrag drin haben sollte, dann müssen sie das anmelden, müssen sagen, das sind aber Geschäftsgeheimnisse, diese Passage muss geschwarzt werden,
dann ist der Datenschutzbeauftragte des Landes Hamburg die Schietstelle.
Aber wenn man jetzt nur die Privatwohnungen rausnehmen wollen würde, warum sagt man dann nicht einfach hier Verträge, die jetzt explizit mit Privatpersonen für Wohnen also dass man sozusagen diesen Fall explizit, wo es irgendwie.
Ja, aber du willst eigentlich ähm keine keine äh Blacklist führen, weil dann wieder passiert, dass die äh unter Umständen, der jemand, der Böses will,
unter diese Blacklist fällt,
sondern wir haben halt gesagt, wir wollen alle Informationen, die irgendwie von Interesse sind, mit einer Öffnungsklausel noch hinten dran und diese privaten Daten, die schützen wir explizit wiederum über ein höheres Gesetz, nämlich das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz. Ja. Das steht ja höher.
Und es geht euch auch im Wesentlichen dadrum, einfach da, wo das große Geld quasi gerollt wird, äh zu erfassen und jetzt nicht irgendwie.
Der Kioskbesitzer an der Ecke, ob der jetzt äh fünftausend oder sechstausend Euro zahlt, interessiert uns ja nicht.
Jetzt vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz zum Abschluss. Warum? Warum wollt ihr diese Verträge haben? Also was ist jetzt ähm was ist so die die Maßnahmen, die über die die Wirkung, die ihr euch davon verspricht?
Na also ähm der Auslöser ist eigentlich, dass in Hamburg diese tolle Elbphilharmonie gebaut wird. Die ist dem Bürger versprochen worden als kostenneutral. Die sollte siebzig Millionen kosten. Das sollten Mäzen tragen und kostet die Stadt nichts.
Mittlerweile kostet der ganze Bau jetzt im Moment fünfhundertfünfzig Millionen. Der die Bauarbeiten liegen still, das Ding ist noch lange nicht fertig und diese fünfhundertfünfzig Millionen bleiben beim Steuerzahler liegen,
und die Verträge sind geheim. Und ähm wir sollen das Zeug bezahlen, wir dürfen die Verträge nicht sehen, wir dürfen nicht sehen, wer da dran Geld verdient. Und das war der ausschlaggebende Punkt,
Das ist auch das Thema, warum die Leute in der Stadt auch alle breitwillig unterschrieben haben, die wollen das endlich sehen, weil Kindergarten werden gleichzeitig geschlossen.
Ähnliche Fälle in Berlin mit den Wasserverträgen. Also eine, ja, Transparenz schafft Vertrauen, ist da wahrscheinlich auch der richtige Titel.
Ja, ist super. Die Idee da später dann in andere Bundesländer zu übertragen. Also das sind dann die Berliner gefordert.
Okay, wir nehmen das dann, wir übernehmen das dann. Vielen Dank. Ja.
Danke euch. Viel Spaß noch.
Ja, tschüss.
Ja, das war Dodja und wir haben uns dann ähm auch noch äh in einem ähnlichen Bereich,
umgeschaut. Äh es gab einen interessanten Vortrag von Stefan Wehrmeier über sein Projekt, namens Frag den Staat.
Hast du den Vortrag eigentlich auch gesehen, der hast du auch verpasst.
Den habe ich verpasst, weil ich bei einem anderen Vortrag zu dem Zeitpunkt war, aber äh mir war ja ungefähr klar, was er da macht. Ich kenne ja ein paar Leute, die ja auch irgendwie in diesem Projekt so ein bisschen mit die Finger drin hatten.
Ich habe Ihnen auch nochmal nachgeschaut, also das ist dann als Ergänzung dieses Interviews äh auch nochmal geeignet, aber der schnelle Einstieg, den bieten wir euch jetzt hier mit dem Interview mit Stefan Wehrmeier.
So einer der treibenden äh Kräfte hinter dieser Initiative ist, eine Webseite aufzusetzen, die Anfragen nach dem Informationsgesetz einfacher machen,
Ja und äh dann schalten wir mal wieder zurück auf den Flora.
Dritter Tag des Kongresses, äh wir stehen noch. Linus, wie sieht's bei dir aus? Bei dir verbessert sich der Zustand eher?
Es geht äh bei mir geht's immer bergauf.
Das ist gut. Ich äh habe zumindest noch keine nennenswerten Abnutzungserscheinungen und deswegen stehen wir jetzt hier ein weiteres Mal in der Cafeteria und haben uns einen Gesprächspartner aus der Menge gefischt.
Und dabei handelt es sich um Stefan, Stefan Wehrmeier richtig.
Genau, das bin ich, ja. Hallo.
Ja, hallo bei Logbuch Netzpolitik. Wir wollten dich auf ein Projekt ansprechen, was du ja hier auch im Rahmen eines Vortrages vorgestellt hast. Das da heißt.
Frag den Staat.
Frag den Staat. Worum geht es dabei?
Fragt den Schade, ist eine Seite, auf der man Informationsfreiheitsanfragen stellen kann und auf der auch die Antworten abgebildet werden, zusammen mit den Anfragen. Also, ist eine super Sache, da macht es wesentlich einfacher, Informationsfreiheit in Deutschland ist sonst nicht so einfach,
Und ähm das macht es auch transparenter. Man kann genau sehen, wie die Behörden reagieren und man kann sich gegenseitig helfen, eine Information aus einer Behörde herauszuholen.
Also was was ist denn sozusagen eigentlich die jetzt die Problemlage, die euch dazu gebracht hat, so ein Projekt äh zu starten?
Wir haben in Deutschland einfach überhaupt keine Informationsfreiheitskultur, wenn man irgendwie nach Großbritannien geht, dann sieht man, das funktioniert alles wunderbar dort. Und äh hier wollen wir das einfach mal stärken und die Leute wissen halt nicht zur Informationsfreiheit, die wissen nicht, dass äh sie das Recht haben auf diese Information,
und äh das wollten wir erstmal, da wollten wir erstmal nachhelfen.
Also welche welche Freiheit, welcher Information ist damit gemeint?
Also wir haben ein paar Gesetze, das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz zum Beispiel, das Umweltinformationsgesetz, das Verbraucher, Informationsgesetz, wir haben sogar so viele Gesetze, dass äh schwerer wird für die Leute als einfacher,
Und ähm aber die Leute wissen trotzdem nichts von diesen Gesetzen. Wir müssen erstmal sagen, okay, ihr habt das Recht,
zum Beispiel äh Verwaltungs ähm äh Behörden, also die Bundesbehörden anzufragen und ähm Informationen aus diesem äh aus Dokumenten und Akten der Behörden zu erfragen,
Ja. Und ähm äh das äh sollten die Leute auch unbedingt tun, weil das macht natürlich unsere Gesellschaft transparenter.
Aber es geht jetzt, ist es jetzt keine reine Informationsseite, wo man sich das alles so durchlesen kann, sondern ihr wollt da, ihr habt da sozusagen wirklich ein aktives System geschaltet, was den Prozess als solchen beschleunigen oder begleiten soll.
Genau, also wenn man auf die Seite geht, kann man auf ein Formular klicken und sich eine Behörde aussuchen und da dann eine Anfrage hinschreiben, also sagen, ich möchte folgende Information haben,
und äh das wird dann direkt von der Seite aus versendet an die Behörde und wenn die Behörde per E-Mail antwortet, dann landest auch direkt auf der Seite,
was natürlich sehr praktisch ist, weil dann muss nicht erstmal hin und her kopiert werden oder weitergeleitet, sondern es wird auf die Seite halt zentral abge.
Wenn ihr einfach per Post kommt, muss der Nutzer leider dann das einscannen und hochladen, aber das geht auch noch. Ähm jetzt das Ziel ist, die gesamte Korrespondenz auf der Seite abzubilden und ähm.
Höchstmögliche Transparenz äh in diesem Vorgang da äh abzubilden. Ähm und das funktioniert auch.
Also auf der einen Seite sollen die nutzen es einfacher haben, das anzufragen. Auf der anderen Seite soll man halt auch äh die gesamte Korrespondenz dort lesen können und nachschlagen. Es soll ein Archiv der Informationsfreiheit.
Was wäre denn jetzt mal so ein Beispiel für so eine Anfrage, die da über diese Seite gestellt wurde?
Also heute auf dem Kongress habe ich äh eine vorgestellt, die war sehr schön. Ähm da wollte jemand einfach ein Gutachten des wissenschaftlichen Dienstes haben, die sonst nicht,
hat es halt beim Bundestag angefragt. Und ähm der hat erstmal nein gesagt, dann hat man das über Umwege bekommen konnte es aber nicht veröffentlichen und dann hat man über eine Googlesuche rausgefunden, dass es doch so ist.
Frag den Staat nicht gegeben, hätte der Anfrage der Anfrage stellende es nicht mitbekommen, dass die Information eigentlich verfügbar ist und nur weil die Community da halt helfen konnte, weil sie darauf schauen konnte auf diese Anfrage,
als herausgefunden werden, dass die Informationen doch verfügbar gemacht werden muss.
Also das war aber jetzt quasi ein eine Anfrage, die gescheitert ist. Ähm.
Nein, die Anfrage wurde abgelehnt von der Behörde, obwohl sie das eigentlich nicht hätte sein,
sollen, ja? Und äh da konnte halt die Community draufschauen und sagen, Moment, das stimmt nicht, jetzt fangen wir mal hier nach und dann hat noch eine grüne Abgeordnete gesagt, Moment, das müsste öffentlich sein. Und dann kam das Ganze so zusammen, dass die Information halt doch öffentlich wurde.
Und und fragt den Staat als Seite, war quasi die Plattform, an der die auf der dieser Fall überhaupt erstmal bekannt wurde, dass es diese Anfrage gab und in der sich mehreren Menschen quasi eine Anlaufstelle hatten, sich überhaupt mit solchen Anfragen und mit dieser im besonderen Auseinander zu setzen.
Genau, das ist das Ziel. Also wir wollen Leute da zusammenbringen, eine kleine Informationsfreiheits-Community quasi ein bisschen äh fördern, dass die Leute halt äh von ihrem Recht wissen, davon Gebrauch machen, sich gegenseitig unterstützen, es zu nutzen. Äh genau das ist das Ziel von frag den Staat.
Also wenn ich das richtig verstehe, äh übernimmt die Seite eigentlich mehrere Aufgaben. Erstmal erklärt sie, welche Möglichkeiten der Anfragen es überhaupt.
Das heißt, man findet dort die Informationen dazu. Zweitens, unterstützt die Seite einem.
Des Anfragens. Ist das jetzt nur mehr so als ein wir schicken die E-Mail für dich oder ähm was äh hat jetzt diese Webseite da konkret implementiert? Also inwiefern,
werdende also inwiefern begleitet diese Webseite jetzt diesen Prozess? Könnt ihr es ja auch einfach selber machen, also.
Genau, also auf der Seite haben wir halt ein Formular und in dem Formular.
So ein Vordruck quasi an was für Paragraphen wir mit erwähnen mit der Anfrage der Stellung drin,
liebe Behörde ist euch klar, ihr müsst innerhalb von einem Monat antworten, so steht es im Gesetz, also nochmal als Erinnerung, dann, dass es eine einfache Anfrage nach dem Informationsfreiheit,
sie damit kostenlos ist. Also wir schreiben da ziemlich viele Paragraphen rein.
Den Antrag möglichst effektiv machen und das hilft den Nutzern schon mal sehr. Wir versuchen gar nicht zu sehr so zu erklären wie das Informationsfreiheit genau dieses Gesetz genau funktioniert im Detail,
das interessiert viele Leute nicht, die wollen einfach nur an ihre Informationen rankommen.
Ihr implementiert sozusagen diesen Prozess und macht auch den Angefragten klar, wir wissen genau, was wir hier äh tun. Brauchst du jetzt gar nicht irgendwie so zu zu tun, als dürftest du mir das nicht geben, weil kennen wir schon den Trick.
Genau, also die Behörden sollen auch gar nicht äh gar nicht drüber nachdenken, eigentlich, ob sie Informationen rausrücken sollen, also äh also der Nutzer soll ich darüber nachdenken, ob die Behörde jetzt richtig ist oder so. Er soll einfach mal anfragen, weil das ist der erste Schritt. Die Behörde kann dann immer noch sagen, nein, dann hat man auch was gelernt,
Ihr müsst einfach die Anzahl der Informationsfreiheitsanfragen erhöhen, die Leute unterrichten, dass sie das können und gucken, was dabei passiert, weil nur aus der Praxis können wir lernen.
Ja und ein weiterer Effekt habe ich jetzt rausgehört ist, äh dass ihr quasi dort auch versucht eine Community aufzubauen. Wie wie aktiv, wie wie groß schätzt du das derzeit äh ein ungefähr?
Also wir sind erst seit sechs Monaten am Start, die ist leider noch nicht so groß, wir haben einige sehr Aktive, die in ihren speziellen Bereichen, zum Beispiel Leimboreliose oder äh die Müggelseeroute oder S einundzwanzig äh Anfragen stellen,
aber.
Sei doch nicht so groß. Wir versuchen das irgendwie größer zu machen, äh jetzt auch wir versuchen jetzt verstärkt wie ähm so ein Blog, wir haben einen Twitter-Account und ein bisschen die Anfragen auch redaktionell zu begleiten und in ein Rampenlicht zu stellen, um halt zu zeigen, okay, diese Anfrage, schaut mal her, das ist interessant deswegen,
und das müsst ihr unterstützen ähm und das versuchen wir jetzt ein bisschen mehr, das haben wir uns für zweitausendzwölf auf jeden Fall vorgenommen.
Wer seid ihr?
Die und halt unsere Unterstützer von frag den Staat, also zum Beispiel transparency International, Access Info,
und noch einige viele Journalistenverbände und die haben alle Interesse daran, dass die Informationsfreiheit in Deutschland gestärkt wird,
Gesetze novelliert werden und verbessert werden, äh weil das fördert insgesamt die Transparenz und zwar aktiv, ja, ist nicht nur eine politische Forderung, wir brauchen mehr Transparenz, sondern wir machen jetzt mehr Transparenz.
Und wo seht ihr da jetzt noch Erweiterungspotential? Also ist die Webseite jetzt so, wie sie ist? Ist das Maximum, was man machen kann oder seht ihr da auch noch Perspektiven, diese ganze Anfrage, Logik und Prozess, diesen diese Prozessbegleitung noch äh zu verfeinern und auszubauen, was.
Also die die Website ist definitiv nicht fertig. Wir wollen jetzt mehr redaktionelle Elemente einbauen, dass irgendwie die Anfrage besser begleitet wird, vielleicht auch ein bisschen Social Media, wir sind uns da noch unsicher. Ähm,
aber wir wollen vor allen Dingen auf die Webseite eigentlich ein bisschen einfacher machen. Zum Start hatten wir uns halt sehr viel von Anwälten beraten lassen. Sehr viel sehr viel Zeug noch drauf, was äh vielleicht irgendwie ähm,
richtigen Prozess äh wichtig ist, aber für den einfachen nicht. Und ähm wir haben eigentlich so äh in in der in der Informationsfreiheit Community äh den Gedanken,
prozess so wie er sein sollte und nicht wie er ist, weil dann bringst du halt die Praxis eigentlich voran.
Ja, also ihr baut sozusagen User-Interface für den Staat.
Das ist äh richtig, das baut der Staat,
äh ein User-Interface für denjenigen, der da Anfragen stellen will, seid ihr da irgendwie mal ins Gespräch gegangen, da vielleicht auch so eine Anfrage AP oder keine Ahnung sonst irgendwelche nennenswerten Standards äh zu machen oder ist es am Ende, ich meine, was geht am Ende wohin? Das ist wirklich eine E-Mail,
die nur wohlformatiert ist, ja, muss man sich das so vorstellen? Es ist eine ganz normale E-Mail, einfach nur ein Brief, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, äh folgende Information hätte ich gerne,
Es ist keine API, also ich hoffe, die denken auch nicht drüber nach, nachher wird auch noch die Systems engagiert oder so, das will ja niemand. Ähm informiert, dass da letztlich ein ein formaler Antrag,
ähm der bearbeitet werden muss. Und das macht jede Behörde selbst äh ähm,
kann man nicht wirklich sagen, jetzt machen wir hier ein einheitliches Interface. Äh da sitzt ein Sachbearbeiter, liest das, äh,
rief zurück. Ähm im besten Fall ähm macht er ein PDF in Anhang oder so. Im Schlechtes Fall druckt das aus und.
Ähm da brauchen wir natürlich irgendwie noch den den elektronischen Weg, das wäre noch viel besser, aber von einer einheitlichen Schnittstelle sind wir meilenweit entfernt.
Ja, na gut, das hätte ich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt erwartet, aber man kann ja mal fragen, ne. Was ähm ja, was was wünscht du dir denn, ähm wie sich das so weiter entwickelt und was sucht ihr noch für Mitstreiter?
Also wir suchen natürlich irgendwie ein paar Programmierer, die das dauerhaft ein bisschen betreuen. Das ist ein Projekt, Open Source, alles auf,
ähm und ähm wir brauchen um die redaktionelle Betreuung, einfach Leute, die Anfragen stellen, darüber schreiben, sich ein bisschen dafür interessieren und ähm das auch kommunizieren wollen.
Finde ich äh ganz cool.
Ja.
Wo kann man sich dann melden?
Also fragt den Staat DE einfach dahingehen und im findet sich Links zu allem Mailingliste zum Beispiel das ist eigentlich der erste Ansprechpunkt und wir haben auch eine normale E-Mail-Adresse erreicht man uns,
Twitter-Account und gibt's auch at frag den Staat. Äh einfach, einfach mitmachen. Okay.
Stefan, vielen Dank.
Fragen offen. Alles klar, Dankeschön.
Ja, hoffen wir, dass da keine Fragen äh offen sind. Ich fand das eigentlich wirklich ein was mir an diesem Projekt besonders gut gefiel, war, dass dass es einfach mal so schön praktisch ist, so dieses, wir müssen mal was tun.
So dieses.
Und auch einfach mal an denen wirklich an den Dingen ansetzen, die es eben gibt, ne? Also zu sagen, so zack, hier, das haben wir, das nutzen wir nicht ausreichend, was ja auch ähm
immer so ein so ein bisschen argumentativ irgendwie. Man sagte, ja wir wollen hier mehr Transparenz, wir wollen mehr Open-Dater, wir wollen das alles irgendwie haben. Und dann äh kommt.
Wollen, wir wollen, wir wollen und wir warten und sitzen da und warten, dass es irgendjemand tut.
Genau und es wird einem ja dann auch teilweise entgegen argumentiert, ja wieso die Sachen, die wir haben, die nutzt ihr doch noch nicht mal.
Nutzt ihr doch überhaupt nicht. Und da da äh reißt sich doch jetzt keiner irgendwie ein Bein aus und wir merken nicht, wie uns mit Informationsfreiheitsgesetzanfragen auf einmal überflutet.
Schöner Nachtrag war ja jetzt hier bei der immer noch äh an immer noch stattfindenden Gesamtdebatte um unseren Bundespräsidenten. Matthias Schindler von ähm.
Also von von ich weiß gar nicht, ist er so eindeutig assoziiert, aber er ist halt vor allem aus dem Wikimedia, Wikipedia Umfeld äh seit Jahren äh bekannt und der hat dann, nachdem die Bild-Zeitung,
den Mitschnitt des äh also nicht den Mitschnitt, sondern das Transkript des äh Anruf.
Wie sagt man, das Anrufes auf dem Anrufbeantworter von äh Herrn Dickmann, von der Bild-Zeitung, äh nachdem die Bildung das also an dieses äh.
Geschickt hat, ich weiß gar nicht, ob's wirklich anders Bundespräsidialamts ging.
Ich zumindest verstanden, ja.
Quasi als Bundespräsident zugeschickt wurde. Vermutlich war es so, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht genau, ich nehme es einfach mal an, weil.
Mathias hat dann halt einfach frech mit frag den Staat, einfach jetzt auch die entsprechende Anfrage gestartet zur Veröffentlichung, weil sie sich ja hier um offizielle Korrespondenz äh äh mit einer Behörde handelt und äh warum sollte man da nicht auch mal Einblick halten?
Unklar, wie das ausgeht, aber auf jeden Fall eine interessante Spielart. Ja, kommen wir zu unserem dritten äh Interview.
Ähm was noch ein bisschen länger ist als äh die, die wir jetzt äh vorher hatten, nicht weniger interessant und zwar sind wir dann Alba Freude über den Weg gelaufen und da dachten wir uns, na ja,
wir hier schon in den letzten Sendungen mehrfach verzweifelt sind, äh ob das aktuell diskussionsstandes rund um, wer ist eigentlich für welche Variante, welcher Vorratsdatenspeicherung ähm.
Lassen wir uns doch mal da einen Einblick aus seiner Sicht geben.
Genau und da muss ja noch betont werden, Albers Sicht, weil ich glaube in Logbuch Netzpolitik der Folge eins haben wir ja schon ähm ein bisschen dazu erzählt, wie es quasi um Alva und die Debatte der Vorratsdatenspeicherung geht.
Um das nur nochmal hier auch klarzustellen. Eiweiß also kein äh,
primär aktivist in dem Bereich, sondern eher ein Meinungsabendender, grundsätzlicher Netzaktivist, der aber nicht da jetzt an dieser Stelle für den.
Vorrat spricht oder so was, das nicht.
Genau, sprich da seine persönliche Meinung aus und äh dafür haben wir eben hier äh denke ich, ausreichend Raum gegeben.
Genau. Also, hören wir da mal rein.
Gut. Jetzt äh stehen wir immer noch hier rum auf dem achtundzwanzig C drei und haben einen neuen Gast eingefangen und zwar begrüßen wir Freude, hallo.
Hallo.
Ja, Alba, hast du eine kleine Auszeit genommen dieses Jahr, hast du gesagt?
Na ja, nicht so ganz ein bisschen. Ich musste auch mal wieder arbeiten.
Man kommt nicht ganz raus aus dem äh Film, oder? Aber es war doch ein sehr anstrengendes Jahr.
Ja gut, ich meine es gab viele Themen, ne? Die Enquete lief weiter, da ist ja eigentlich schon ein Vollzeitjob und ähm bisschen war's beim Zensur war natürlich auch immer zu tun. Es zieht sich ein bisschen in Grenz
da war die Sachen ja weitgehend abgeräumt haben, aber es kommt ja immer wieder mal ein bisschen was hoch und ähm so, dass ich dann halt doch ein bisschen Zeit hatte, mal nebenher wieder ein bisschen Geld zu verdienen.
Ja
Ist auch schwer zu sagen, weil ich sehe keinen Jahresrückblick äh äh machen, aber was wir auch hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik schon mal angesprochen haben, ist so diese fortgeschrittene Konfusion rund um das Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
der einen Seite ist es ja nun alles schon mal auch höchstrichterlich ähm na ja, wenn ich abgeschmettert, aber doch zumindest eingeschränkt worden. Trotzdem hat man in der Politik nicht gerade so den Eindruck, dass äh es weniger gefordert.
Viel streitet sich um konkrete Modelle und.
Es herrscht zumindest bei mir und bei dir glaube ich auch, Linus, so ein bisschen die Verwirrung, was eigentlich gerade so der Stand der äh gegenseitigen,
und Forderungen ist in den einzelnen äh einerseits politischen Lagern, aber dann auch in den netzpolitischen Lagern.
Ja gut, ich meine, das ist natürlich eine,
schön komplexe Geschichte, über die man jetzt drei Stunden reden könnte. Klar. Ähm nein, also das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat auch vollkommen zurecht meines Erachtens. Die Vorratsarten bei Speichern gestoppt und ja auch.
Speicherung sofort gestoppt, also nicht nur gesagt, ihr müsst jetzt mal ein neues Gesetz machen und habt eine Übergangsfrist von zwei Jahren, hätten sie auch machen können, sondern haben gesagt, sofort das Gesetz ist nicht dick und die Daten müssen vernichtet werden.
Ähm.
Ähm das Verfassungsgericht hat aber auch gesagt, dass ein Gesetz möglich ist. Man hat halt so ein paar Rahmenbedingungen vorgegeben, was sie als Mindestanforderung haben,
die liegen für mich viel zu hoch, also äh ähm zu hoch im Sinne von, nein, sie siegen zu niedrig, ja. Oben und.
Ich wollte dich jetzt gerade schon rausschmeißen.
Die Anforderungen sind zu weich. So, jetzt haben wir, glaube ich, eine richtige Formulierung.
Anforderungen sind für mich zu weich, weil sie doch die sechs Monate komplett zulassen. Sie lassen äh ähm alle Datentypen komplett zu äh und so weiter. Sie haben aber Einschränkungen bei dem Abruf.
Also äh ähm der Abruf der Daten soll entsprechend eingeschränkt sein auf schwere Straftaten, ähm aber gespeichert werden darf alles, was so das Herz begehrt. Ähm das ist so ein bisschen der.
Das Zugeständnis an die EU-Richtlinie, die eben diese Daten vorgibt.
Was haben die denn äh dann verboten?
Sie haben die konkrete Umsetzung der EU-Richtlinie verboten, so wie sie im Gesetz stand. Ähm aber sie haben nicht gesagt, dass die EU-Richtlinie grundsätzlich nicht mit deutschem Gesetz,
deutschen Verfassung vereinbar wäre, äh hätten sie auch aus verschiedenen äh europarechtlichen Fragestellungen nicht so einfach machen können. Ähm.
Und das Problem ist halt jetzt, dass die EU-Richtlinie da ist und äh das wichtige Punkt ist eigentlich, diese EU-Mische, die muss in dieser Form weg.
Weil sie äh einfach viel zu viele Daten verlangt und viel zu lange Speicherfristen mindestens vorsieht und äh äh das volle Programm. Aus diesen Sachen kommt man halt nicht weg, wenn man die EU-Richtlinie nicht.
Ändert oder ganz abschafft. Und ich denke, das wird in der Diskussion häufig vergessen in Deutschland, weil ja, das ist irgendwie Brüssel und ist weit weg.
Genau und jetzt haben wir irgendwie äh ja diese Situation, dass,
auch schon gesagt wird, ja, wenn wir aber diese Richtlinie jetzt nicht umsetzen, dann kommen irgendwann die äh Strafzahlungen aus der EU, dann gibt's wieder andere, die sagen, Quatsch, äh da müssen wir keine Strafe bezahlen, das ist alles Unsinn. Und dann gibt's natürlich jetzt die verschiedenen Parteien, die sagen, wir,
uns irgendwie zu diesem Thema Vorratsdaten sprechen. Gehen wir mal irgendwie kurz durch. Äh Linkspartei ist, glaube ich, unseres Wissens dagegen. Das hatten wir im,
gesammelt. Die Grünen haben sich dagegen positioniert. CDU ist.
SPD äh haben wir ausreichend behandelt, äh hat also irgendwie einen Kompromissvorschlag und möchte sie gerne eindämmen.
Ja, es gibt halt unterschiedliche Meinungen bei der SPD, ne. Ähm ähm was man halt sagen muss, also nochmal ganz kurz EU-Richtlinie, diese EU-Richtlinie ist da und es ist tatsächlich so, dass diese Strafzahlungen drohen. Man kann natürlich sagen, ist nicht so viel nebenbei in Kauf. Also kann man auch, denke ich,
so vertreten. Äh ähm aber rein formal ist es natürlich richtig, diese EU-Richtlinie. Da muss umgesetzt werden.
Weißt du, wie diese Strafzahlung, wie hoch die ist?
Ich glaube, die waren jetzt nicht so hoch, deswegen sagte ich ja man muss sich deswegen jetzt nicht unbedingt den riesen Topf.
Aber rein formal ist es natürlich richtig, dass es da ist und deswegen ist der oberste Priorität muss in der europäischen Diskussion haben diese Richtlinie wegzukriegen und nicht irgendwie die Strafzahlungen zu vermeiden.
Man könnte sich auch mal überlegen, was so eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist ja auch nicht umsonst, ne. Also da könnte man ja vielleicht sogar über das Ökonomische Argument der Sache billiger, ja.
Ja, das Bundesverfassungsgericht ja äh ähm gesagt, äh müssen die Provider machen, deren Pech,
äh ähm hat diverse Gründe, warum sie das gemacht haben und kann man auch ein paar Sachen kritisieren, die da in dem Prozess, glaube ich, nicht so optimal liefen, aber oder in dem Verfahren ist ja kein.
Ähm.
Aber gut, das ist eine andere Sache. Ich denke, also wichtig ist, auf EU-Ebene muss das diskutiert werden, dass es wegkommt und nicht irgendwie wir wollen eine Strafe eindämmen oder verzögern oder sonst was. Weil, ich meine, es betrifft ja auch nicht nur uns, sondern auch unsere lieben Nachbarländer und,
auch da kann man ja dann sagen, sollte man vielleicht einen kleinen Blick dahin haben und sagen, die VDS sollte in dieser Form auf jeden Fall nicht da sein.
Dann hätten wir, hätten wir dabei ja die gleiche äh Debatte, wie jetzt grade hier, weil dann, also wenn man sagt, man schafft diese Richtlinie ab,
wer ja da letztendlich das Gleiche wie hier, also es gäbe irgendwie die Entscheidung, das wegzulassen, dann würden sich sofort alle melden und sagen, ja, wir müssen stattdessen aber dann.
Machen, Plus machen, wir müssen IP-Adressen speichern. Irgendwas würde ähm sage ich mal die Vorratsdatenspeicherungsbefürworter.
Ja dann wieder ins Rennen bringen. Also hätten wir die gleiche Debatte wie hier.
Na, also ich meine, auf EU-Ebene,
äh ähm denke ich, wäre eine brauchbare Lösung, sowas ähnliches wie wir bei dieser äh Netzsperren ähm Richtlinie hatten, dass,
äh ähm es gewisse Mindestvoraussetzungen gegeben sind, unter denen überhaupt so etwas gemacht werden darf.
Also die wirklich einen Grundrechtsschutz einsetzen und natürlich auch, weil's immer um wirtschaftliche Harmonisierung geht, auch die Provider einer wirtschaftlichen Harmonisierung zu führt, dass die in allen Ländern die gleichen Rechte haben.
Dass es dass es da einfach eine eine vor allem um die Obergrenzen geht und ob ein Land und was ein Land davon umsetzen möchte, das den Ländern überlassen.
Wird es schwierig haben bei einigen EU-Mitgliedsstaaten überhaupt durchzusetzen, sondern Mehrheit dafür.
Das Ding komplett abzuschaffen. Wird wahrscheinlich schwierig, aber wenn man das so wie bei den Sperren hinkriegt zu sagen, OK, es bleibt den Ländern überlassen, zu sagen, ob das überhaupt einsetzt, aber wenn sie es einsetzen, müssen sie mindestens diese und diese,
Forderung einhalten, die entsprechenden Grundrechtsschutz äh ähm gewährleisten. Dann wäre schon mal einiges gewonnen gegen.
Könnte das ein oder andere Land sagen, nö, machen wir gar nicht, oder andere Länder sagen, hey, wir haben hier, wir reden hier über verschiedene Datenarten und verschiedene Datenarten müssen auch unterschiedlich behandelt werden, die sind unterschiedlich.
Gefährlich. Äh warum soll man die denn alle gleich behandeln? Ähm was übrigens auch das ist, was ich als als Position.
Was uns in der SPD, die ich ja in den Punkten hin und wieder mal ein bisschen,
Tipps geben oder berate. Ähm es ist, da gibt's halt auch verschiedene.
Äh ähm in vielen Parteien ist das halt die Innenpolitiker, die eher sagen, wir brauchen das, ansonsten geht die Welt unter.
Ähm und die Netzpolitiker, die das eher gegenteilig sehen. Und die aktuelle Linie ist halt die Bundestagsfraktion soll äh ähm.
Jetzt mal.
Anhand von verschiedenen Kriterien entscheiden, wie wie man sich dazu positioniert. Äh dazu werden zwei Gutachten gemacht. Technisches und juristisches. Das Technische habe ich geschrieben,
das juristische der äh ähm der Professor Rosenhagel und ähm da muss man mal gucken, was jetzt dann die Fraktion daraus macht.
Okay, aber vielleicht können wir nochmal ganz kurz diese so abschließend noch einmal diese Begriffsklärung. Ja, was ist also äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung? Wird ja jetzt dann in verschiedenen ähm Wegen ausgeführt und man merkt so richtig, wie Befürworter, die
Begriff auch irgendwie weghaben wollen, ne? Wie gesagt, Plus und äh alles und dann Hauptsache, es heißt jetzt endlich anders, ja und um diese Debatte irgendwie so ein bisschen zu resetten, was was verbirgt sich jetzt hinterher so ein Begriff wie zum Beispiel.
Na gut, also ich meine, ähm in der gesamten Diskussion hatten wir schon, haben wir auf beiden Seiten, wie immer in einer hitzigen politischen Diskussion äh ähm die Begriffs.
Punkto. Äh also ich verstehe unter Vorsadenspeicherung auch was anderes als manche anderen Untervorasadenspeichern verstehen. Im Wesentlichen die Sachen, die mit dem Gesetzevorort, Datenspeicherung zur normalen Praxis hinzu.
War auch einer der Beschwerdeführer bei der Verfassungsbeschwerde, weil ich das für äh untragbar gehalten habe, was da umgesetzt wurde. Ähm.
Wir haben einfach so ein bisschen erlebt in den letzten Jahren, die Definition war böse.
Sache X ist eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung, also ist X böse, also ist derjenige, der X vertritt.
Und das ist natürlich ein bisschen ein bisschen sehr einfache Sache, weil weil da man äh äh ähm,
verständigen aber ob dann,
Thema X schon Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist. Ja, das ist dann wieder schon eine schwierige Sache. Also da da das ist ein bisschen.
Und X könnte quick free sein zum Beispiel oder.
Nein, halte ich für für Quatsch. Äh.
Was wäre das denn jetzt nochmal genau? Einmal für die Hörer, wir müssen immer uns wird vorgeworfen, dass wir äh auf zu hohem Niveau immer reden.
Okay, ich versuche's. Mal ein bisschen runter zu machen. Äh bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung geht's ja darum, dass alle alle Kommunikationsdaten, die ähm mehr oder weniger täglichen Leben anfallen, auf Vorrat für sechs Monate gespeichert werden sollen, falls die Strafverfolgung.
Benötigen.
Von von allen Personen.
Von allen Personen, sprich, wer hat wann mit wem telefoniert.
Mobiltelefon, wo hat sich diese Person aufgehalten? Damit kann man dann komplette Bewegungsprofile bilden, vor allen Dingen bei der modernen Smartphones, die sich alle paar Minuten irgendwo einwählen, weiß man dann alle paar Minuten, wo sie an welchem Ort sich diese Person.
Das ist natürlich äh äh ein Unding. Also in meinen Augen ist es ein Unding, weil damit ist es einfach möglich nachzuvollziehen.
Bewegungsprofil zu bilden, wer, wann, an welchem Ort war und es gibt ja diese von Malte Spitz, äh, die Vorratsdaten, die von Zeit online visualisiert wurden und die zeigen sehr schön, wie gefährlich das ist. Es wurde auch mit dem Grimma Online-Award ausgezeichnet, äh, müssen auch relativ.
Danach suchen mit der geeigneten Suchmaschine.
Link im Blog.
Gibt's natürlich noch viele andere Daten. Also es gibt die normalen Telefondaten, es gibt die E-Mail Daten, wer hat wann, wem eine E-Mail geschrieben? Ähm.
Und es gibt die IP-Adresse. Das ist die äh Adresse, mit der man im Internet eingewählt hat, wenn man sich ins Netz einwählt, dann kriegt man ein temporär meistens eine Adresse zugewiesen.
Mit dieser Adresse ist man dann äh erreichbar beziehungsweise mit dieser Adresse liest man dann auch entsprechende Webseiten oder kommuniziert mit anderen Leuten. Ähm.
Ja das ist klar, ich meine aber der der Ansatz ist ja im Prinzip das äh Umdrehen, dass man sagt, wir speichern nicht immer alles schon mal auf Vorrat, ja, sondern wir schaffen nur diese Möglichkeit, quasi
on-Demand, all das zu speichern in dem Moment, wo es klar ist, dass hier ein berechtigter, wie das auch immer zu definieren ist, ein berechtigter Anspruch der Behörden besteht, das eben zu sammeln.
Dass das Problem bei Quickfree ist, ne, man man speichert dann auf Verdacht, wenn irgendwie ein Verdachtsmoment vorliegt. Das Problem ist nur, diesen Verdachtsmoment hast du erst nachträglich. Dann sind die Daten schon weg.
Die Daten schon weg sind, dann kann sie sie nicht mehr fließen. Also das heißt, wenn du umsetzen willst, musst du.
Speichern, weil du kannst natürlich nur Daten, die du.
Speichertast auch während einfrieren, weil sonst, wie gesagt, sind sie weg. Eine Mindestspeicherungspflicht voraus. Und macht sie noch schlimmer, weil Quickfries dann auf Zuruf die Daten länger speichern.
Ich denke, das kann man bei den Daten machen, die die Provider aus Abrechnungsgründen sowieso.
Ich dachte, das beispielsweise, ich dachte, das wäre so gemeint gewesen, dass man überhaupt erst ab dem Moment, wo ein Verdacht besteht, anfängt zu speichern.
Was ja auch sinnvoll wäre, wenn man sagt, dass es eine Präventivmaßnahme, dann sollte man den Verdacht ja vorher haben.
Aber das funktioniert so nicht. Also weil, weil, weil du, du, also wenn du einen Verdacht gegen eine Person hast,
dann hast du meistens genügend Verdachtsmomente, dass du eine Telekommunikationsüberwachung machen kannst oder ähnliches. Ja. Sprich, äh du hast ganz als Ermittler, die haben Ermittler, haben ganz andere Instrumente, die auch viel bedenklicher sind natürlich, ja, komplette Abhörsache ist natürlich viel bedenklicher. Aber,
im Verdachtsfall haben sie das in der.
Du meinst, das gibt's eigentlich schon und das.
Das gibt's also ähm die Komplettüberwachung von verdächtigen Personen, ja und vor allem bei schweren Straftaten sowieso. Die gibt's schon. Ja.
Ach so, du würdest also sagen, ein ein Quickfrieß hieß sie jetzt, das macht man eh die ganze Zeit, da darf aber keiner ran. Und äh ab dem Knopfdruck äh wird dann, werden diese Daten auch behalten und
ähm werden auch in Zukunft dann voll umfänglich erfasst und deswegen ist Quick Freeze gefährlicher als äh die Vorratsdatensprechung in der Ausführung, wie wir sie im Moment hätten haben wollen.
Jein, ja, also äh zwei, zwei Beispiele, mal ein ein Hardcore-Beispiel und ein Weiches, ja? Ja. Also typische Vereine, also ich war's irgendwo, ist ein Meuchelmord, ja. Irgendjemand wird umgebracht und dann will man halt wissen, mit wem wer telefoniert hat.
Machen, vorher. Ja, weil wenn er tot ist, kann er nicht mehr telefoniert. Ach so, der der Ermordete. Der Ermordete, weil man weiß ja nicht, wer's macht. Ja, klar. Mhm. So, also, jemand wurde am Morgen, wir wollen gucken mit wem hart er telefoniert,
Wenn wir jetzt sagen, alle Daten müssen sofort gelöscht werden, dann kann man das natürlich nicht.
Man sagt, Quickfries kann man die Daten auch nicht mehr ein, Friedensweise sind ja schon weg. Ja. Das heißt, man könnte das nur machen, ein Quickfries, wenn man sagt, okay, die Daten müssen eine Weile gespeichert werden und dann frieren wir sie ein. Dann haben wir aber.
Speicherfrist, die man sich speichern müsste und dann noch die Verlängerung, weil man ja jetzt einen Quickflies gemacht.
Von daher, also das ist äh äh unter Umständen dann als sehr viel Bürokratischer und natürlich auch viel gefährlicher. Ähm.
Beim Mord hat man natürlich immer eine andere Situation, weil das auch eine sehr schwere Straftat ist, bla, bla, bla. Das ist klar. Äh ähm man sieht es besser an einem anderen Beispiel. Ganz typischer Fall. Und das ist das, was den Ermittlern am meisten Probleme macht, sind die IP-Adressen.
Irgendjemand macht online eine Straftat und das kann natürlich auch um äh ähm relativ harmlose Taten halten äh handeln, also irgendwelche Beleidigungen, Stalking, äh ähm ähnliche Sachen.
Ähm ja beschreibt irgendwas in dem Forum oder macht online Betrug, sonst was.
Dann hat man die IP-Adresse von dem Täter, die kriegt man dann vom Dienstanbieter, der Ermittler.
Aber die Tat ist halt schon ein paar Tage her oder ein paar Stunden oder ein paar Wochen und mit Quick-Frieskor, nicht weiter, weil der hat sich ja schon längst abgemeldet vom Internet.
Hat schon längst eine neue IP-Adresse. Das heißt, Quick Free ist ein kompletter Unfug in dem Sinne, weil die Daten sind gar nicht mehr da. Außer wiederum, man würde sowieso eine Speicherfrist für die Daten vorschreiben.
Genau das will man ja verhindern mit also es ist so eine Art Paradoxon, ja? Also man kann nur das einfrieren, was eh da ist und wenn man das dann einfriert, dann hat man eine Speicherfrist Verlängerung mitkriegt.
Das heißt, Quickfries ist nur dann sinnvoll, wenn die Daten sowieso aus anderen Zwecken da sind. Beispielsweise Abrechnungsdaten oder Einzelverbindungsnachweis äh bei Telefonaten oder äh äh Notfall zu technischen,
bei E-Mails und so weiter. Da kann man das von mir aus machen. Ähm aber in allen anderen Fällen funktioniert es nur, wenn man eine Speicherung auch irgendwie verpflichtet.
Dann hat man eine Verlängerung dieser Speicherung und das wollen wir ja eigentlich nicht. Das ist Problem an.
Ja und was ist jetzt Plus?
Bus ist genau das mit diesem äh also so wurde glaube ich das von der von das Konzept genannt,
das ist das mit einer Mindestspeicherpflicht. Also man muss mindestens etwas speichern und dann kann man Quickies obendrauf setzen.
Also eigentlich ist irgendwie alles das Gleiche, das heißt bloß immer irgendwie anders.
Ja, gutes ist natürlich in dem Hinsicht schon anders, dass natürlich der bürokratische Aufwand des Kriegfries dazu kommt, sozusagen.
Kann unter Umständen gerechtfertigt sein, ähm aber bei den bei dem normalen Sach, also ich sehe es dann eher eher kritisch und denke äh ähm dann sollen sich die Ermittler gefälligst beeilen und nicht aufm Quickflies drauf setzen, ja, sondern.
Sondern halt direkt die Daten entsprechend dann abfragen, wenn sie eh noch da sind.
So und äh vielleicht auch ganz kurz abschließend deine Position, für die du dir damals sehr stark kritisiert wurdest, ist äh das Einzige, was gespeichert werden soll, sind IP-Adressen.
Ähm genau. Also man muss halt die Daten sich anschauen, wie tief die Eingriffstiefe ist,
bei, bei Mobilfunk, Standortdaten, da kann man eben Bewegungsprofile machen, da greift man sehr tief in die Persönlichkeitsrechte der Betroffenen ein, auch bei Telefondaten, wir waren mit wem telefoniert hat oder E-Mail Daten und so weiter,
Da sollte man sich auf die Daten beschränken, die die Provider sowieso speichern.
Äh ähm wie wir wissen, in der Zwischenzeit ähm speichern viele Provider aus technischen Zwecken, aus Abrechnungszwecken die Daten einige Tage, teilweise bis zu hundertachtzig Tage, was schon.
Sehr grenzwertig ist. Ich denke, das muss dringend eingeschränkt werden, also diese Speicherfristen, die den Provinern erlaubt ist, muss gesenkt werden, darf nicht mehr so lange sein, wenn sie es für eigene Zwecke benötigen.
Die sind zwar häufig legitim, aber bitte nicht so lange und zum anderen, wenn die Ermittler diese auf diese Daten zugreifen,
muss meines Erachtens auch hier das gelten, was das Bundesverfassungsgericht als Mindestanforderung für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
äh ähm vorgesehen hat, nämlich äh Informationen der Betroffenen, äh ähm Richter vorbehalt, revisionssichere Protokollierung. Und diese ganze Schnickschnack, alles, was das Bundesverfassungsgericht,
da gesagt hat, muss auch da dann gelten bei den Daten, die sowieso da sind.
Ähm okay, das heißt also jetzt kurz als Beispiel auf den Fall, den du grade nanntest, jemand wird im Internet verleumdet, ähm derjenige, der verleumdet hat, soweit er sich nicht anonymisiert hat, äh hinterlässt auf diesem Server auch die Absender IP,
und man kann dann also sagen, okay, ich wurde hier verleumdet, fragt erst den, den Betreiber dieses Forums, wer von welcher IP kam dieser Eintrag? Der sagt, ja, der kam von der und der IP und damit ist diese IP äh.
Quasi mit mit der Speicherung von IP-Adressen zu einem Anschlussinhaber ähm ist zumindest dann der Anschlussinhaber identifizierbar. Und das aber auch immer.
Ähm hier ein, also das ist das tägliche Geschäft, ne, also so von Neuem sieht natürlich auch noch höher, Betrug und Verleumdung kann auch in vielen Fällen, dass das vergessen wir leider,
häufig ähm sehr harte Sachen sein, wo halt Leute, die,
die die auch kaum Ahnung vom Internet haben, ganz übelst beschimpft werden und unter Kindern und Jugendlichen und so weiter. Also das sind kleine Sachen, die jetzt komplett harmlos sind, sondern die die Opfer dann schon ziemlich hart treffen.
Ja, das können wirtschaftliche Konsequenzen haben, das kann alle möglichen stören, ja.
Genau, das kann das kann einem den Job kosten und so weiter. Also das sind das sind schon schon heftige Sachen. Also es gab auch ganz krasser Fall, da waren ARD-Film letztens ein Selbstmord von einem Jugendlichen äh ähm wo es dann einen Spielfilm draus an gemacht wurde und so weiter. Also,
Das ist jetzt natürlich die Ausnahme. Muss er sich jetzt nicht hochspielen, ne? Ähm so. Also, von den Daten, wo ich vorhin erzählt hatte, mache ich das eine Ausnahme,
Das ist die IP-Adresse. Da sage ich, okay, weil die Eingriffsintensität sehr gering ist, man kann eben bei der Speicherung der IP-Adresse beim Zugangsprovider nicht nachvollziehen, welche Webseiten ich aufge,
überhaupt nichts von mir. Er weiß nur, wenn die Polizei kommt, ich habe hier die IP-Adresse eins, zwei, drei, vier. Wem gehörte die? Am ersten Ersten zwotausendzwölf, um neunzehn Uhr dreißig. Dann könne sagen, das gehörte zu diesem Anschu.
Also Analogie ist ja dabei so ein bisschen die äh das Kennzeichen.
Die Telefonnummer. Ne, also das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat auch in seinem Urteil zuvor, zur Abspeicherung diese Unterscheidung schon gemacht und hat gesagt, dass hier eine sehr geringe Eingriff da ist und dass dieser Eingriff nicht ausreicht, um,
äh äh das einzuschränken und dass dass man hier eigentlich eine Ausnahme machen kann und sollte und dass das dann auch für minder schwere Straftaten erlaubt sein sollte. Weil eben die Eingriffstiefe extremst gering ist,
Es ist ganz groß die Angst von vielen Leuten, ja rankommen, das hilft aber der Urheberrechts äh Abmahnindustrie äh für Massenabmahnungen.
Ja
Das hilft ihr nämlich nicht, weil die Urheberrechtsmassenabmahnungsindustrie,
auch schon in den letzten Jahren und Monaten immer Abmahnungen verschicken, weil äh wir hatten diese Speicherung,
de facto für diese Zwecke nie,
vor dem Verfassungsgericht hat kurz nach Inkrafttreten des Gesetzes in einer vorläufigen Eilentscheidung gleichgesagt nur für schwere Straftaten dürfen die Daten verwendet werden,
und dann, wo das Ganze kippt. Und es gibt immer noch Abmahnungen. Wie machen die das?
Die schicken eben sofort ihre Briefe raus, beziehungsweise ihrer ihrer ihrer Speicheran.
Haben, die sofort die Daten. Das kann man sogar in Echtzeit machen, selbst wenn man die Daten sofort löscht,
können die das in Echtzeit machen. Die haben auch ein zivilberechtigten Aufkunftsanspruch an den muss man rangehen, man muss an Abmahnbesen rangehen, man muss in ganz vielen Bereichen daran gehen, wenn man die Abmahnungen verhindern will.
Das hat mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherungsdiskussion eigentlich überhaupt nichts zu tun, weil die brauchen keine vor die Abmahnung,
Es hilft uns überhaupt nichts, die sässige Situation weiter zu haben oder irgendeine andere Situation, wo es keine wie auch immer Datenspeicherung gibt, weil sie kommen an die Daten trotzdem an.
Jetzt habe ich auch noch einen letzten Punkt, nachdem wir schon zweimal äh den letzten eingeleitet haben. Du hast ja, äh wenn ich dich richtig verstanden habe, eigentlich von Anfang an dafür plädiert, dass es dass die Kernlösung äh eigentlich nur auf europäischer Ebene äh
kann. Habe ich dich da richtig äh verstanden? Und wenn ja, was äh heißt das vor allem so für diese deutschen Netzpolitikanstrengungen? Wie kann das europäischer werden oder wie müsste das oder findet das schon statt?
Also ähm wir haben halt diese Richtlinie und solange die nicht geändert wird, ist sie da. Und solange es da nicht irgendeine Umsetzung gibt, solange die Richtlinie da ist,
irgendwie die EU-Kommission äh äh zufrieden stellt,
und so eine äh so ein Gesetz wollen wir nicht haben, weil das zu viel Daten, zu lange speichert,
ähm wird man damit nicht zurechtkommen, von daher ist es klar, es muss an dieser Richtlinie irgendwas gedreht werden,
es gibt ja auch schon verschiedene Bestrebungen da was zu machen, es gibt ja so 'ne Evaluation von der EU Kommission und dann gibt es verschiedene Überlegungen die richtigen hier umzugestalten,
mal heißt es ja vielleicht klappt's, mal heißt's, vielleicht auch überhaupt nicht, mal HSA, vielleicht kriegen wir die richtige Gans weg,
äh also da sind ganz viele verschiedene Meinungen unterwegs äh und jede zweite Person, die man fragt, sagte was anderes. Ähm.
Also ohne das, aber das ist klar, wird man halt das Zeug nicht weg.
Wird Gurtenberg das schaffen, als neuer Kämpfer für die Freiheit des Internets?
Ja, ja, der gute Kati hier.
Äh da brauchst du jetzt nicht mehr drauf zu achten. Da bin ich.
Alver. Vielen Dank. Vielen Dank für deinen Beitrag hier.
Ich hoffe, ich konnte ein bisschen Licht in das Dunkeln bringen.
Konntest du? Auf jeden Fall. Vielen Dank.
Danke Alver, schönen Kongress noch.
Ja, Licht ins Dunkel bringen, das ist äh ein Thema vieler Vorträge gewesen auf diesem Kongress
und
Einer derjenigen, die da äh schon seit Jahren sehr sichtbar auf der Bühne, nicht nur auf der Bühne des Kongresses sind, sondern sagen wir mal auch auf dieser internationalen Bühne der Berichterstattung immer wieder äh sichtbar sind
ist äh Jacob Eppelbaum ein ähm,
wie soll man sagen, also ein äh an vielen Fronten,
aktiver Hocker der einerseits durch,
eine sehr große Kompetenz auffällt, der sich also wirklich verdammt gut auskennt, selber aktiv mitprogrammiert bei vielen Projekten, vor allem Tor.
Und der auch auf dem Kongress äh einen längeren Vortrag gehalten hat zu der Situation Tor und der Bedrohung durch,
Staaten, Zensur, die ausgeführt wird et cetera.
Also nur für die weniger damit vertrauten Hörer ein Programm, das es ermöglicht ähm einmal,
anonym im Internet,
aufzurufen, also hauptsächlich ist es erstmal für für Websurfing gedacht, man kann es aber auch mit ein paar Hacks dann irgendwie auch auf anderen Protokollen vernünftig nutzen. Also einerseits anonym im Internet unterwegs zu sein und dadurch, dass man,
anonym,
unterwegs ist, auch äh wegsperren zu umgehen, also da quasi man geht, der Traffic wird also durch mehrere verschiedene Rechner geroutet, bevor man an seinem,
tatsächlich ein Ziel ankommt und dadurch hat man im primär, wenn man jetzt beispielsweise in China ist, den Vorteil, dass man einerseits Zensur frei und andererseits anonym
im Internet unterwegs ist und das ist natürlich für in solchen Ländern eine enorm wichtige Software, die da.
Wobei auch immer wieder betont wird, auch das ist nicht perfekt und niemand kann dafür garantieren, ich glaube, es kommt auch im Gespräch kurz nochmal zur Sprache. Ja, aber ist auf jeden Fall eine, eine, eine sehr wirksame Verschleierung
Aktivitäten, da wo man normalerweise eine wirklich sehr klar und deutlich nachvollziehbare,
hinterlassen würde, macht das Tor einem potenziellen Überwacher
äh sehr schwer, sehr schwer äh ja.
Sehr viel äh sehr, sehr viel aufwendig.
Genau und von diesem Kampf handelte auch der Vortrag in dem Interview haben wir jetzt weniger versucht äh den Inhalt dieses Vortrages äh aufzugreifen.
Der war übrigens auch, ich glaube zum einen, der, wenn mir das richtig erzählt wurde, wir haben, glaube ich, zu dem Zeitpunkt das Interview mit Alva geführt, äh der Vortrag gehörte auf jeden Fall zu einem derjenigen, die irgendwie den mit Standing Ovations am Ende begegnen.
Ja, der auch wirklich viel reflektiert wurde, also wo ich sehr häufig gelesen habe, dass Leute immer der Meinung waren, das wäre jetzt auch wirklich eins der Highlights. Ich kann's
zu diesem Zeitpunkt selber jetzt noch gar nicht so in den Kontext stellen, weil ich noch dabei bin, den ganzen Kongress irgendwie nachzugucken. Soweit sich eben die äh Zeit dort findet, ist ja immer das Elend, ne? Wenn man da ist, kriegt man eigentlich vom Kongress am wenigsten mit
die besten Methoden, die beste Methode, dem Kongress zu folgen ist, ehrlich im Fern zu bleiben und das ganze vom heimischen Wohnzimmer aus zu verfolgen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall äh der Vorteil, wenn man sich,
zu Hause die die Talks anschaut, aber wir können ja mal, wenn wir jetzt eh schon dabei sind, Talks zu empfehlen, welche können wir denn empfehlen? Also wer, also, heißt der Vortrag, den Jacob Apple-Baum mit Roger Dinge da eingehalten hat.
Sagen, die anderen Empfehlungen, die machen wir dann nochmal am Ende äh und bündeln die nochmal so ein bisschen, jetzt hören wir erstmal rein, was zu sagen hat. Das ist nämlich äh alles sehr aufschlussreich. Äh,
Kleiner Hinweis noch, in der Mitte wird's eine Unterbrechung geben, weil uns da die Batterien ausgelaufen sind, da geht da inhaltlich wenig verloren. Ähm und dann geht's auch gleich wieder weiter, also hier in zwei Teilen Jacob.
Are you ready? Hä? Jay Kay ready.
Teller ist okay.
Ahm.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik unterwegs, der letzte Tag des Kongresses, man könnte fast sagen, die letzten Minuten,
aber äh wir haben uns hier nochmal einen Gesprächspartner geangelt, mit dem wir uns auf Englisch unterhalten möchten, weil ja aus den USA kommt. Linos, bist du bereit?
Ich bin bereit, ja?
Hallo.
Äh
Ja.
Ah, ich denke, das ist der neueste Import.
Living in Berlin, in Bingen, Wolf wird das Event für Event.
Für die.
Es ist.
In Holland diese Events.
Einen.
Genau.
Everybody.
Internet.
Vom vom Mai.
Real System.
Selbe.
Ähm Speaking of Tor ähm äh Government.
And somit.
Das sind.
In
Das ähm Partikel Programm Linus und hier ist in.
Äh
ähm äh.
Bei bei heißt.
Now Riesenfour optimist. I don't know.
Ja
Genau.
In Germany you can safe. Ähm Internetpolitiks.
Ähm Freedom auf die Internets, bei ähm Hillary Clinton and Ski Hess äh Band Scotty Advisor, ähm it all seams.
From Government Institutions.
NWK Sitz.
Äh Internet
ähm keine äh.
Ja, für den Witz haben die Batterien auch ihre Sekunde gebraucht und sind dann direkt leer gegangen.
Also das hat sie das Aufnahmegerät dann überfordert. Aber äh wir machen hier gleich weiter. Äh wir waren ja beim super Thema und damit geht's dann hier auch gleich weiter.
Einen Extension.
In
Wir haben die die.
Realisiert.
Cinesry make its oder da ist der Legobirton.
Zero. Zero.
Fortissa.
Thank you very much.
Vielen Dank und auf Wiedersehen.
Immer sprachgewandt und wünschte sich, dass äh,
in Deutschland als die Regel. Aber so schlecht war es gar nicht. Es gab ja einige interessante Talks, äh ein paar mal rausgepickt, die hier ähm.
Den netzpolitischen Bereich äh streifen. Ähm da gab's zum Beispiel auch nochmal einen Vortrag,
Politik hacken,
der sich quasi anschließt an einen meiner letzten CREs, mit der äh hedonistischen Internationale, die sich dort auf der Bühne äh ein Stelldichein gab.
Was hast du denn noch auf deiner Liste?
Also wir haben, ich hab jetzt mal draufgeschaut, was so netzpolitisch interessant war, neben natürlich frag den Staat, den wir ja dann auch schon erwähnt und verlinkt haben. Dann gab es Christian Bahls, das ist der junge Mann, den ich auch schon mal erwähnt hatte, vom Moke ist e.V. Den Missbrauchsopfern gegen Internetsperren.
Einen Vortrag gehalten über die Vorgänge im Bündnis IT,
die ihren ursprünglich mal so die guten waren und irgendwie quasi ein offenes Netz mit trotzdem,
Schutz vor,
illegalen und bösen Inhalten irgendwie schaffen wollten. Und da ist er also auch Mitglied drin, hat davon so ein bisschen erzählt, dass er den Eindruck hat, dass sich da langsam die Dinge ein bisschen zum Bösen wenden.
Gleiche Christian hat auch äh einen Vortrag gehalten, den mit äh Counterlobby institutions und zwar zusammen mit dem Jeremy Zimmermann
Von Lack vor der Tür die Net, einer der sehr, sehr bekannten europäischen Netzaktivisten.
Mhm,
mit dem ich dann auch später äh nochmal in seinen gemeinsamen Runde war äh im Rahmen dieses Kongressradios, was der Thomas Luninger gemacht hat auf dem Kongress.
Da gab's eine eine schöne Runde, haben noch einige andere äh teilgenommen. Von Telecomics, äh
noch ein paar andere, also es war eine interessante Runde, wer da nochmal reinhören möchte, auch das sei empfohlen an dieser Stelle.
Verlinken wir auch. Dann gab es noch
den ja sowieso die Keynote natürlich von FG Nimorosov, der äh immer so als der Cyber-Kritiker wird er eigentlich immer äh bezeichnet, der unter dem,
Äh
eine Keynote darüber oder die Keynote darüber gehalten hat, wie die ganzen westlichen Firmen eigentlich die Überwachungs- und Unterdrückungssoftware,
in die Diktaturen liefern, Software und Hardware in die Diktaturen liefern.
Damit sie nochmal ähm anmerken, dass also Keynote war ja bisher auf dem Kongress,
tatsächlich eher ein Talk, der sich wirklich explizit an das Kongresspublikum gewandt hat und so ein bisschen über die Zeichen der Zeit spricht. Das war wahrscheinlich auch die Motivation, diesen Vortrag auszuwählen. Aber es ist nicht so, dass dieser Vortrag in diesem Stil einer wirklichen,
Begrüßungsansprache, sage ich mal, äh geführt wurde. Von daher ist da so ein bisschen mit der Tradition gebrochen worden.
Vortrag schien eher so ein bisschen aus dem Koffer zu kommen, ne? Und der hatte also ich war da noch so ein bisschen beleidigt, dass äh FG die Mauser am nächsten Tag schon wieder irgendwo aus Weißrussland twitterte, ähm das,
werde ich jetzt erstmal von einem von einem achtundzwanzig C3 Keynote Speaker nicht erwartet, also wenn ich mir so, ich erwarte eigentlich von dem von dem achtundzwanzig C drei Keynote Speaker, diese große Ehre, dann hat man gefälligst auch die ganze Zeit auf dem Kongress rumzurennen und äh
äh
Sich den Rest auch noch zu geben. Ja, ja, das.
So wie letztes Jahr Rob, ja, ich meine, Robs Kino hat letztes Jahr fand ich enorm großartig,
ja? Das äh das war eine Wahnsinns eine Wahnsinnssache. Rob-Gong.
Da eine der das einfach schafft eine Kino zu halten. Die hat aber nämlich, das ist mir dann nachher aufgefallen, die Tradition, mit der da eigentlich gebrochen wurde beim diesjährigen Kongress, ist, dass die Keynote einfach später gehalten wurde. Die hat nämlich Corry Doctor gehalten.
Und zwar erst abends,
Das war aber auch, glaube ich, noch Tag eins und der hat, jetzt fällt mir der Titel gar nicht mehr so genau ein. Der hat also wirklich einen ähm sehr schönen Talk gehalten mit dem
Titel
Meine Güte. Wo er sich so ein bisschen damit auseinandergesetzt hat, ähm was das eigentlich im Prinzip alles inzwischen ein Computer ist und wie wir aber gleichzeitig,
immer mehr Computer kaufen, die immer mehr beschnitten sind, in ihren Funktionalitäten und so diese Idee des ähm Heimcomputers.
So völlig irgendwie an den Rand gedrängt wird. Und welche.
Sagen wir mal das Prinzip des General Purpose Computers, da wo man irgendwie alles tun darf, ne, halt zu dieser iPad äh App Store Effekt.
Alpertisierung und äh immer ausgeschlossener, immer,
mehr exkludierende und inkludierende Systeme, also die einerseits sehr viel ausschließen und andererseits so ein bisschen den Nutzer in sich einsperren wollen und so, da also großartiger, großartiger Vortrag, den er da gehalten hat. Call Doctor liest ja dann auch ab.
Schafft's trotzdem äh das absolut äh mit absoluter Begeisterung da,
einen Vortrag zu halten, der Tipp ist einfach, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen irre, ne? Es ist wahnsinnig, was.
Bin trotzdem kein kein Freund davon.
Du bist kein Freund davon.
Also ich bin also von seinen Themen, seine Themen finde ich mehr als legitim, nur ablesen finde ich einfach.
Ja, ich ich.
Das sind halt diese Schreiberlinge, ja, das sind.
Aber er kann das, er kann das.
Es ist abgelesen, bleibt abgelesen, weil äh das ist einfach, wenn du, wenn du schreibst, du schreibst nicht fürs Reden.
Du schreibst fürs Lesen, das ist einfach, also das kann man zwar auch anders machen, aber den Eindruck hatte ich jetzt auch nicht so unbedingt,
wie auch immer. Man kann das sicherlich auch gut machen und es gibt auch Hörbücher, die man irgendwie äh ne, gut verfolgen kann, aber es ist äh grenzwertig, weil es einfach dann auch nicht interaktiv ist in dem Sinne. Ja, es geht nicht,
berücksichtigt, einfach dann die die Zuschauer dich in dem selben Maße. Da fragt man sich auch, irgendwie hätte man jetzt nicht auch Texas Beach machen können, ne.
Also stimmig stimmig absolut mit dir überein.
Stelle das einfach mal in den Raum, hm?
Trotzdem hat dieses Ding irgendwie das hat einfach gesessen, das war gut. Und das war die Keynote,
zum achtundzwanzig C drei am Abend dann erst dann gab es noch auch in Saal eins am ersten Tag von Anna Roth.
Den Vortrag Sachsen dreht frei,
wo sie sich so ein bisschen mit den äh Demokratie, den Rand der Demokratie betretenen Maßnahmen in in Sachsen äh auseinandersetzt, auch sehr ähm sehenswert, denke ich.
Also vor allem jetzt der Umgang mit Nazis, beziehungsweise eigentlich eher der Umgang, den Nichtumgang mit Nazis, äh ja, wo wirklich,
eingedroschen wird noch und nöcher, äh aber ja, wie sagt man so schön, auf dem rechten Auge blind trifft sie hier an der Stelle sicherlich ganz gut. Das ist,
erschreckend eigentlich, was sie da zusammengetragen hat.
Das stimmt und dann gab's noch ein äh from Press Freedom to Freedom of Information von so äh Reporter ohne Grenzenaktivisten, die da auch noch einen Vortrag gehalten haben, der, denke ich, auch sehr interessant ist.
Das wäre jetzt so die Abdeckung des netzpolitischen Feldes, würde ich jetzt mal so sagen. Ja. Beim diesjährigen Kongress.
Also solltet ihr davon noch irgendwas nicht gesehen haben, ihr habt noch ein bisschen Zeit und Lust. Feier up your brothers. Folgt den Links in unseren Shownotes und dann äh könnt ihr das Kapitel achtundzwanzig C3 dann auch zumachen. Wir machen das jetzt auch.
Und sagen tschüss und die nächste Folge kommt ganz flink hinterher. Viel Spaß, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Auf Wiederhören.